un bain de foule du soleil et une
certaine liberté retrouvée
les britanniques en profiter avant
l'heure de la phase 2 de leurs
déconfinement et bien que le pays soit
le deuxième le plus touché au monde avec
plus de 38000 mort le royaume-uni
élargissez mesure autorisant ainsi les
réunions de six personnes et la
réouverture partielle des écoles une
stratégie jugée dangereuse par le comité
scientifique qui conseille le
gouvernement britannique s'est risqué
pour deux raisons premièrement je pense
que le taux de reproduction du virus est
juste en dessous de 1
et donc il n'y a pas beaucoup de marge
de manoeuvre est donc de petits
changements peuvent faire passer ce taux
de reproduction au dessus de 1
donc je pense que c'est la première
considération je pense que l'autre chose
la plus importante est que nous avons
encore beaucoup de cas ici dans ce pays
le nombre d'infections que nous avons
est d'environ 8000 nouvelles
contaminations chaque jour en angleterre
des chiffres qui n'affole pas le
gouvernement britannique qui compte
essentiellement sur la discipline et la
prudence de chacun
nous avons tous notre rôle à jouer il
s'agit d'un effort national et nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer
si vous avez des symptômes vous devez
vous isolez immédiatement et passer un
test des consignes avec un système de
test et traçage qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité du conseil scientifique
un comité qui compte une cinquantaine de
membres avec des perspectives
différentes pour certains d'entre eux la
stratégie de test et de suivi des
personnes contaminées n'est pas assez
rodée pour contenir l'épidémie
quoi qu'il en soit le royaume uni se
prépare à reprendre des activités
normales avec notamment le sport les
courses hippiques seront les premières
compétitions sportives à reprendre dans
le pays ce lundi avec l'application de
mesures strictes telles que les
contrôles de température et la
distanciation sociale il y aura des
prises de température pour tout le monde
à l'arrivée tout le monde devra suivre
un cours de formation préalable sur la
distanciation sociale et ce qu'il faut
faire et à quoi s'attendre
il ya des affiches dans l'hippodrome
explique en quoi faire je suis
extrêmement confiant dans le
professionnalisme des personnes au sein
de ce sport pour mener à bien cette
tâche et que nous puissions continuer à
bien prendre soin de nos chevaux et de
nogent reste à savoir si ces mesures
seront suffisantes pour empêcher une
nouvelle propagation du virus
une partie du comité scientifique en
doute fortement